[Music]
whoa it's a mirror face guy I am your
confessor sorry pal I don't do
confessions but I know this dweeb named
Mike he'd totally be into it I am here
for only you Oh sexy why don't you show
me what's underneath that robe
honeybunch
son it's Muller can't get me copper I
mean Muller
I mean copper are you so morally vacant
that you cannot confess to your crimes
even within your own mind yes
No uh where's the mirror guy he was fun
I brought a a cheeseburger for the
Confessor but I guess you're not him
wait no no no no I'm a confessor yeah
yeah I could do that I did it all
conspiracy obstruction collusion
conjunction junction what's my function
I want the truth I can't handle the
truth
are you not alone drifting in a sea of
self-deception
I already know about the money
laundering and the data mining and the
dirty deeds and your Russian hotel room
oh yeah
still got it you'll never be free unless
your confession is absolute okay I made
Erik ugly on purpose and you are a liar
or you not yeah it's true half the crowd
of my inauguration we're blow-up dolls
yes now the
is flowing like an icy fjord I'm jealous
of coal miners cuz they can get away
with doing blackface showers Oh little
Donny's afraid for a little Donny more I
don't even like having sex with women I
just want people to think I did
Johnny made Noddy on mommy's favorite
dollies before she came home I moved on
those dollies like a bitch you're bad
bad little boy mommy was always in
charge but being bad made me in charge
daddy diaper boy give me more I can't
read I once ate God poop I'm getting
dementia like my mom and dad and mom
[Music]
well not with everyone some people
incredibly actually like you but I tried
to pay them and then I paid them not to
talk about it because nobody likes me
nobody wants me your closest confidants
have all Abed I've absorbed down into
the infinite reach of my unending
investigation
gates gates done burned up the couple of
nany Papa bus Ivanka know they're all
[Applause]
now you will join them the everlasting
purgatory of the justice system
no never join you
bye bye Johnny
[Music]
you